hey everybody welcome to another episode
of wrists of fury I'm Kelsey cook and
today I'm very excited to be joined by
one of the best comedians out there he
was the runner-up of America's Got
Talent
please give it up for true [ __ ] no one
else here class okay we start people
roll oh yeah yes wait a little go down
from there I'm so happy to have you on
I'm very very nervous I've seen videos
of I've seen videos of this
yeah and man it's just it's like looking
into the eyes of us I can't look at you
at cotton at the clubs I'll see you
there
but right now I can't look at your eyes
I keep it Jesse I don't know why this is
just ever so I'm like like that's gonna
make a difference - I know I was like
hey are you ready and you're like I'm
not like you thought I was just gonna
immediately throw a ball in yes I don't
know that I don't know that we're not
playing right now I don't know if this
is part of the game oh my god I feel I
feel like I've just shaking you up so
much you just you brought it on so
casually you were just like yeah yeah
like my whole family like we're world
champions and stuff and like I've got
like a show right boob right where I
beat the asses of grown men and can I
say yeah okay I was I was very impressed
and like any good
like any good athlete you got a study
tape beforehand
did you watch some tape I watched some
tape bro and not just of you go what you
know I'm really I'm really keen on like
the books and the rules inside of it my
performance will will be underwhelming
but but but as far as guidelines goes
I'm your guy so I might whoa I might as
well just be roughing this so I think
you're the first guest who's watched
tape like not this show but like you did
you go down like a YouTube rabbit hole
and you not - I mean I ended with like
motocross but I got there the first day
I saw or not but I mean I started on
football yeah yeah I spent a lot of time
watching motocross and I'm bummed that
this isn't motocross no I watch you like
dude it's just impressive and you're
just very like you're very casual to
with the guests like I like that I'm
talking about your show as
let's just let's break you down as a
show I like that yeah you're just man
just so confidently quiet confidence
over there and I just it's a it's a it's
impressive and I don't know I'm just
trying I'm I'm complimenting you and
it's it's genuine but I'm so I'm so
nervous I mean I stutter as it is but
like now well you know somebody's you're
studying the rule so my mom wrote the
world table soccer almanac see this is
what I mean when I was saying earlier
when I was saying earlier that she
flexes real casual I can't laughs in the
next I don't know if my love can hear
that but if I face outwards of my chest
can you hear how good I'm doing in the
next room what sport oh oh what's over
there the ping-pong convention uh-huh so
hard your is killing mama Rhoda
your mom wrote the rules foreword by
Woody Harrelson big foodie small guy
big big foosball guy but yeah my mom's
considered like the historian of the
sport and so she has like all these
records and yeah it's very it's very
technical that's why I like that you you
know some of this now I mean it's pretty
easy to dominate a game that you
invented you like the older sibling he's
like well like Emma not monopoly well no
well if you roll they're like no that
dice isn't that one's not in play right
you can't buy that property cuz I had I
was gonna see it next time so you go
around Philly that's me yeah well I was
the older sibling so I know that's
[ __ ] right now me too really I also
I appreciate that you rolled in in camo
pants which is a very white-trash
appropriate response so thank you for
that I feel like you're ready to go and
make me take my beer helmet off but I
had one I had it your very own brand
I really liked it so we're gonna play
one game to five to start just to like
warm up one game to [ __ ] to five points
yeah so it's actually always to five but
on the warrior tables they put ten for
like over time and stuff like that right
well just play to five will kind of you
know the talk just see how it goes and
then we'll do a second round and we'll
do things that make it easier for you to
beat me later on you're like a doctor
talked
talking the kid before the shot right
now I guess it's gonna hurt I know it's
gonna hurt why are you talking if color
the wall doesn't help this pediatricians
office yeah I'm a Gannett where's my
husband
so we're just gonna like real casually
I'm gonna I'm gonna spank that ass and
like you just get thanks to her casually
guy no just lube and up yep
[Music]
okay so you guys a falls on your side
okay you can all right you can start if
you would like to so as somebody is that
regulation I don't know it seems are you
okay with that yeah right
you can start if you want so how it
works now is even though they have the
holes on these tables you actually start
regulation play with you put the ball
right here on your five bar you ask your
opponent
are you ready they say ready and then
you have to touch the ball to two men
right and wait a second
like in soccer remove the ballpark so
right right okay so I ask you if you
okay I ask you if you're ready
yes and then and then when I say ready
okay but I only ask you if you're ready
when I'm ready right yes
all right we're gonna give me a good ten
minutes goes by I'm how much tape do you
have all right
oh my god all right so I'm I am I'm the
black or the red yeah I'm going chic
okay yeah by the way can I say something
about your on the Black team on your
Wikipedia page under your comedy genres
it says black black no one else told me
that they're like giving you you do
black comedy I was like oh yeah I'm
gonna yeah yes clearly
oh my guy that everybody yeah anyway cuz
that made me laugh ha how do I let you
know alright here we go
okay are you ready I'm ready okay whoa
okay okay
dribbling does it count if I if I didn't
see it go in I know they call that a
ghost ball but I really believe in that
goes so goes ball all right ah how does
that feel so far I yeah hurt so like
yeah it's that sucked
that was the worst I go I get the ball
you do get this I got cuz I lost make
off so goes like this regulation is so
you ask if they're okay right yeah again
yes
I can't imagine you've gotten less ready
that's winning the last round but but
but let's do again okay
I don't like I'm like the sound it makes
when it goes in guys
crisp how iceberg lettuce man so we had
your friend preacher Lawson on the show
yeah yeah how did how did he did he
score when he came in he scored the
first goal and he exploded
he did a jump and a high five under his
legs he did like the splits at some
point he screamed and then I just
destroyed him after that
it was like he got so high and then I
dropped him off I mean he did it yeah he
was gonna do all that anyway that's
creature yeah he kicks he jumped the
push-ups and he and then he and then he
scores it's like Cirque de Soleil and
like extreme bodybuilding and he's the
whole package but a lot he's an admiral
as a person do you think they're gonna
do better than no no nope I mean based
on like the trajectory of so far I don't
know if we're counting those first two
points but if we are then no it's not
sure it doesn't look that good and
what's weird is like if I can if I if I
if I if I if I may be so just I what's
weird is is like I'm lining up with your
guys like I'm lining up as you're doing
that and I don't know how you got like
he's like right here and my guys are
like right where the goal is so I don't
know where you shot but I'm not
confident that's assault
it's a that's a guy oh you feel like
some sorry I don't know man just it just
Fanta you felt I don't know man it just
doesn't if these things like seem like
awesome I don't know alright so by the
way so right now these guys are not
blocking the goal do you see that oh so
so you would have to move in to here or
move into here because if you could
block with all that like people would
never score oh my sneezes oh they're
just outside of it yeah
use two men at a time yeah see I said
that all right are you ready I'm talking
to me so I don't need you to talk I'm
talking to myself
ah drew hmm activate those camera pans
all right Kelsey cook are you ready I am
ready to see the problem is is that it's
it see but that's what I mean like okay
all right no more all right wait does it
matter wait that's game right cuz you
want no we got the five okay so I got
two more chances to mess this up I'm not
gonna go that way because you assume is
that way can I go this way yeah
absolutely
are you ready I'm ready okay good yeah I
didn't know don't say it like actually I
could I mean I have does that that was
it does count but it's like in a
tournament you'd be like you do this
this is what people do they touch the
table as if to say like that wasn't a
clean point it's just some weird twist
all sign language I don't know that's
what people do okay game point what hang
on because it might not be if its your
game point but perspective is like
because if it because to me I could I
get five game points right now I have to
get five
I have Arioch in the clinic this is game
point I say no it's [ __ ] this is game
points for me so let's not call it game
pool it's not over right now okay are
you the fact the fact the fact they made
me ask five times is the worst are you
ready not that way aggressive aggressive
back pacify there's nothing to punch huh
[Music]
so we're gonna we're gonna pick out some
things and change it okay so you grab
one okay what number do you have I got I
got I got three three okay so three
means that you get to start every point
with the ball on your forward so you
just gonna have like a straight shot at
me like a penalty kick basically Wow
okay and I I got two so that means we
never done this I can only score with
this guy so even if the ball starts here
I have to pass it back to score from
here I can only use this man to score so
you're saying is it's gonna be all the
more embarrassing when you do that yeah
okay if I do that you might win now you
can just start here and I can only score
from there to there just back and forth
hello all right so is that so this is
whose ball okay um okay all right should
you want to try your guys oh no you're
gonna keep a mug my opinion yeah I can
use these guys but wait that's thank you
sure on me yeah I can only see you're
just you just saw a left hand pretty
much freedom I mean I can do this okay
well you know what it's one hey it's one
way ended yeah no I'm not I'm angry but
I'm not I'm I'm livid but I'm not bad
yeah I mean it's not I'm not dis I'm a
good parent I'm not mad like you think
I'm gonna say I'm just disappointed no
no no no I'm all of the negative
thoughts towards you tell it Kelsey cook
right now so don't even look at me right
now cameras and all nine of you don't I
don't swear I'm cool okay
and being a baby comic NBC man you know
who's following you to bring out the
real droolin you know got those camo
pants ready to go okay so you start this
all here oh that's right yeah oh yeah
use your advantage - I do that
immediately name okay all right so
that's where that goes now do I still
thank you so I still have to tap
twice right nope you know you can just
go for it which is gonna make me sick it
has to say it like no no you do whatever
put it throw it place it in it that's it
can you get that one
what what number is that man I can't
even I can't even look at you the same
after this like I can't see you at the
last act I can't we read that's B move
hope comedy and Philly's gonna go good
for me I ran you out of to never show
your face in this town again
I go to Philly there's man all right all
right here we go okay oh no spinnings
all right no oh you're all good oh you
do another room yeah yeah sorry no
spinning
okay so just that guy okay so oh that's
like nerve-wracking because I can score
myself - oh-ho okay it goes back to me
technically yeah yeah cuz obviously what
the last person to touch it right um if
it's stuck between those two rods it
goes back to the defender gotcha gotcha
now what okay so you just you know needs
to five again yeah this is upsetting
dude it's more than upsetting hmm okay
why do your hand oh I have that okay
is it grips they're both on tennis
rackets actually buy him a big five and
you're wrapping yourself okay
anyway
oh you know you're so much more more
more deliberate you know what I mean
you're just so like and I know that
that's Oh [ __ ]
oh you been at weight oh if you scored
on yourself that'd be the only way how
how I was I was moving it though I was
moving it you know what I'm saying hey
hair can't get through the prongs of
combs write that down hair can't get
through the prongs of comb that's cuz
it's moving is the dumbest thing I've
ever played
I hate this I don't know I don't know
why I feel bad for that camera guy cuz
he's the camera on that right now and
I'm net and I'm and I don't know him
it's like the windmill and then he go
you mean like you got time it I need
everything this is a numbers game get
the that - well please okay all right I
don't know what this is
motocross foosball hybrid that I play
you don't know me oh all right fine you
[Laughter]
know what you know what your lives I
don't know if that counts us two or
three that I made it take two you take
two and I hope you feel good about it so
that's a light that's not a camera um
but you're throwing it up to God for a
second okay so what do I do it do it do
I get a show here cuz I don't know I
think over here should be good I don't
know I don't know what this means now I
guess I guess call comedy and tell him
I'm back okay
the mayor of comedy okay well I guess I
start with a ball now because
technically you scored on me how
whatever you need to do to feel good
about yourself like I did I'm just gonna
let you do I got it I got it I got a
drive home so to me a lot of sitting in
my car
in the park after this it's not looking
in the rearview mirror so just making
sure these are solid matters okay
all right okay you ready yeah but you
but this has to go back yeah I have to
go backward so you might want try and
defend this way which is weird
yeah okay so it's a sent it back towards
me no nice no Kelsey nice try
no I'm gonna get me scoring myself and
all that will be for naught you're like
yeah did you see he scored two and one
but remember the next round when he
scored on himself
aggressively scored on himself what is
that masturbating all right we need a
live studio audience for this show very
I don't think okay ready
yeah can you say whatever is that that
relation whatever I [ __ ] guess all
right here can't get to the prongs after
[Applause]
all right no no no okay so now we start
there right because you see somehow you
scored on that one yeah I don't know I
really know how I'm actually gonna move
that guy like just ask you okay just
like so just so okay all right
here we go while someone's off the high
chair that's right he has to go back
every time I'm like well you better just
and do you have a specific defensive
strategy right now in this right now
it's - like right now it's it's chaos
it's just like just okay so now Oh No
okay thank you all right so this is what
crisis averted
so this is what kits for this is what
Kelsey would do right now okay I've got
the ball
yes nothing I have I have it okay the
game is in play
um Kelsey's soda is like it's cat it's
it's a it's jazz it's just a stroll on a
stick you know and and and I and I and
I'm - ah you know I'm - I'm - jack
tattoo jacked up man I came in with too
much of like a like I'm sponsored by him
- energy drink and I and I and I just
got to be more like it's cool babe Oh
back to you babe Oh back to you babe
it's up there oh oh it's back to me
affection affectionate terms for these
little men we're close and little in the
locker room chatting like hey that was
that was that was a real big loss
remember when you got aced and the whole
points you did get you cheated see that
pull out a build up not a lot of
delivery okay whoa oh
defense wins Super Bowl I don't know how
well sensitive the law of mics is I'm
sorry I was loud defense Seattle
Seahawks a few years ago probably
defense
penalties is her own silly mistake did
we do this yet no Wow Chris okay
[ __ ] no that's such a terrible feeling I
knew that was gonna happen
hey you're gonna bawl that's kind of
devastating yeah I don't I don't like
that feeling that you're embarrassing oh
wait
yeah you are alright man I am I am
behind the sore winner but who are you
oh are you ready oh boy yeah I don't
know alright alright
Kelsey got so bored she was just like
I'll just do it myself okay see what see
like I don't know if you guys caught
this on camera but like my guy is soft
here so he because the ball hit him and
then he went whoa and then it went in
what he went he towed from towed from
Mario's or I don't know guess so yeah
obscure reference but it was so good wow
thank you so I was so good but so I
don't know guys the dubbed the w WD 40
guy
the maintenance I guess it's okay what's
the point of having the guy if the Bulls
it's an idiot tip yeah put your guys is
just like this ask you right because it
has to hit it really hard then for it to
knock and go all the way around
oh I see but if you're like this it's
gonna go through okay smart smart smart
keeper then their feet forward feet
forward guys Lord before we guys toes up
goes up game point for Kelsey thank you
yeah game points for drew just being no
spinning post betting sorry no spinning
along nice people you like that with
aggression
just add a dime
ah how did you get I don't know how you
got that this is really hard
how's your time drill okay
did you play any other sport is growing
up like what's your experience coming
into this I I actually played some some
foosball in daycare in daycare yeah
Oh like boys and girls club when people
do that yeah yeah so it was a lot like
that and I mean but but like sports
sports I played baseball and and let me
baby on my speed no accuracy I just
psych you out a score on yourself wolf
what happened I feel like I could get it
three all the time in oh you literally
can't go by you
I need a bank is what I need to do whoa
it's kind of what I'm guys I don't know
if it's too late to change your bets no
oh
call your bookies mm I don't like this
[Laughter]
this oh I do not like oh that's close
you want that yeah I don't know if you
know how to use it but that's what that
is
Wow oh you have taken a turn this is
where Kelsey asks me if I'm ready and I
go one second oh you are the worst
you are the wors I shouldn't have let
you go edit don't handed it edited any
of that out okay this is where a Cal soo
it's where she uses in her own comedy it
passes it back to herself a metaphor if
I've ever heard one going backwards much
okay folks
anybody chillin chillin it right now
okay are you ready - yeah all right all
right enough of this enough of this
tomfoolery [ __ ]
got it true uh-uh oh god just remembered
it's fourth floor I can't I don't have
oh Jesus no room for error
this is infuriating
yeah just scary just easy that's where
you would have scores oh yeah - my heart
is racing I really don't like it being
this close I mean how do you feel right
now if you don't like anything sports no
no I mean I feel like thank God we just
sat down so Durrani's like this isn't
like the detective in the shower yeah
that's how I yeah okay Wow
I mean you scored four points no I swear
to have been illegal yeah I scored yes
but I sort I scored two food balls and
two of our ping pong ping pongs so my
records showed that to us we're actual
[Music]
you know what happens now what so we
play two ball so that means we each have
a ball here we go 1 2 3 go
and I go we each hit it and you have a
score both balls to get a point if we
each score when it's a wash okay so you
don't have to like pass back and forth
it's just 1 2 3 go and you hit it ok
this is winner-takes-all so if you beat
me in this ok you would win everything
all right
but if you lose I've done I've done a
little background work on you ok and I
reached out to your front creature who
also talked to your girlfriend Oh No so
he could devise a punishment before you
what's this so what wait I didn't so
this is from preacher asked preacher as
like hey drew was coming on the show I
need to think of some good punishments
for him what are things he hates I don't
like that you're assuming that I was
gonna lose but yeah I mean well it's
kind of a lot of funny ok yeah I come
alive I'm a late bloomer
okay what's your yeah preacher says he
hates his own comedy that's true and
parties for him and his ex that's true
bring her in as a surprise which we're
not doing oh okay God and you're alright
that's the punishment was what that what
you just did so I'm Rhett Rowe fitting
when I lose to now we don't even need to
need to play I feel like I lost so so
much oh my god then he asked your
girlfriend and she said ah my ex its
source
she said he hates tomatoes mushrooms
sharks spiders and snakes with a picture
that says tear him down so she's she's
looking for you to be in some pain as
well okay that's kind of exciting adds
weird support system I have okay all
right what's gonna happen if you lose
how's that a huge we're gonna pull up on
YouTube one of your earliest oh let's
stand up and we're just you and I are
just gonna roast it together while you
eat some Tomatoes
mm okay okay all right okay mm-hmm
yep Wow okay so this okay mm-hmm and I
will say yeah sure yeah i'd you know i i
looked up the video stuff
the one we're what like it's infuriating
as a fellow comic your videos from like
seven years ago are still [ __ ]
hilarious
and hold up and you are killing them now
so just dude my okay oh man
dad let's uh I need to I need to I need
to win right I need a win right now
god I need it like wow that's it's it's
it's that's just oh that's so mmm ah
that sucks so good man that's all right
all right look
do you respect it I know I accept these
terms but this is the worst day of my
whole life so let's just it's less 1/2
its last day we're so much go real low
note alright so you have to do right yep
okay so liners up however we work how
are you please and then on go we both
said it all right hey and we're playing
five okay all right yeah one two three
go there's their stakes player amazeen
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
not none not my comedy wait that doesn't
count right cuz I know
this is the one that's the one you'll
Schouler here's the one you'll score
later there there there there I like how
it's just put yours in and we'll play
this one why are we you don't know all
right here we go one two three go or we
could put both in two there's that as
well we could have done the bouquet all
right one two three oh oh it's a wash Oh
what eternal is that was it okay one two
three
[Applause]
let the American Sign Language have that
angle it's hard to defend it
- if I'm shot okay one two three go you
lose sight for one second
hey guy okay one chance I had bro row
that's Paul something [ __ ] up a lot
for people lately
alright ready yeah one two three go see
I feel kind of like nervous shooting
back here now because one two three pop
put the click get it ready right
hey tomato my tomatoes with mustard
please for god sakes
me a human condiment to eat with this
nightmare of a devilish food oh cool
oh cool you're a vegetable that's 90%
water why don't you just why don't you
just pour a Brita on my burger you [ __ ]
do you want some ketchup yeah I don't
really care dude
I really don't care some tomato on
tomato
I feel like mustard would make it worse
oh it's kind of weird see this is heavy
or - how weird is that guys heavier or
maybe I maybe I'm weaker on my right on
todd todd trickery trickery dude
trickery it's not regulation here
conspiracy you guys are all you guys are
all complicit in this and this upset
huge upset and i am upset that's word
okay I looked at the crew to that
responder hall there's an insane person
playing a professional did yeah there
you go
my what a what a childish way to settle
in a don't matter when when just when
did we go out hill and just your
integrity your character I mean yeah
this is designed to break people that's
what it is it's designed to break people
and then I go on it I go on a tirade on
Twitter after this and my career is
ended
you're after more than just who I am
feel like our friendship is just
dissolving before my eyes
alright so that's we're on that right
now
let's get er done I'm really I'm no I
just know I'm enjoying this but not that
like I'm enjoying yeah everything that's
not foosball I'm having a good time but
there isn't a little sparkle and you're
in your heart that says maybe I can come
back know when ya
ooh me you yeah okay me yeah all the way
back
whoa boom its trick whoo this way no no
me oh now over here you don't know it's
a wash
maybe you left the full set
don't call me in his car the thermostat
is over here and I'm changing it I'm
lowering it your bill the electric bill
I don't know what the utilities are in
here but you better damn well hosted
that that they're included it's at 64
right now oh hello 63 that baby's gonna
kick real on that's gonna mess with
sound for a perfect for continuity you
better you put good luck good luck at it
and editing this episode I don't think
I've ever seen such a colossal meltdown
on the show are you done no there's
another point Kelsey what can I just I
never this isn't even my home like you
have home advantage so you've got the
crew and they just bigs
they silently they support you and my
girlfriend doesn't even support me from
a text message now thought that was in
the past
maybe that let's do this my god I don't
think of that one later do ya I got I
got another one for you thank you so
much yours don't don't
yeah one two three go
nope nope nope that's oh you are my dude
what's up baby
alright okay let's do it let's just do
it let's just do it what do I sit for
watchin for watching my dumb my dumb
jokes it's it it get ready I'll do it
for you oh I'm dry dry dry fruits are
tough man man what's it what's this
what's the speech impediment
do we have tomatoes I would rather eat
my comedy and watch Tomatoes they see
you hey oh my god just like just a
couple just pop a couple these are so
good they're so good and so is your
comedy and you know that mmm just just a
couple bro mmm Kathy oh my god you're
Russian are you not just from this or
the tomatoes oh it's that oh my god
exactly in a morbid way as this is how I
would like that
oh this is tough it's a good table not
drivers phone numbers approximately when
you started on the number oh it's a
sympathy clap for six take God's it
probably wasn't a phone number get it we
get it
there's five numbers already oh my god
well nobody can be meaner to you than
you oh you're good you don't have to eat
any more okay yeah you're good you're
good we'll just throw that away
oh just that was just a reaction from
the comedy I was like a violent allergic
reaction I don't joke oh yeah man and
that's it but also the tomato is always
like it's like it's having its its its
its its its its its senses rape that's
what it is and I don't want to use that
word liberally I'm sorry but when you
have terribleness going in your mouth
and in your ears you have no outlets and
I didn't even agree to it I did okay it
wasn't right he's somewhat it wasn't yes
it was on terms that I that I that I
didn't like true my dude my mouth tastes
like a grandma's garden right now you
know what I mean you know that old house
you visit and you're like hey I know I
only want to be here for holidays that's
what it is right now in my mouth and my
ears you are your champion your beast oh
don't don't patronize Nathan thank you
yeah
oh no you are I mean not up for this
ball but a comedy you know that you're
really good thank you my whole face was
that it was everything it was clogged
pores I was one giant blackhead
white head sorry not according to them
away yeah now according to Wikipedia you
don't know me hey guys I'm drooling I
have a podcast a podcast called did I
stutter okay folks
yeah oh yeah yeah okay right and and
okay plug it plug your Instagram okay
his comedy clips are unreal I watch them
in public and I'm the person that's like
choked laughing on airport shuttles
watching them they're so good Thank You
Kelsey um yeah oh it's just might just
Bella drew Lynch drew Lynch was taken so
I had to do I had to do I did you like
it yeah you like that douchey thing Ravi
comedian comedian went legit yeah
comedian yeah so to his website and go
see him on tour um you can follow me on
instagram at Kelsey cut comedy at my
website is Kelsey cook calm for tour
dates please subscribe to the all things
comedy youtube channel
go watch the other episodes and by erisa
fury shirt we'll see you guys next time
I don't know it
what are we sorry sorry oh my god drew
oh my god thank you guys for watching
another episode of erisa fury be sure to
pick up your official erisa fury shirts
that they are buttery soft they feel
like Dalton skin they're lovely be sure
to LIKE and subscribe to the all things
comedy channel and you can get the
shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you